so the other night at our collider
screening q a robin mentioned that you
really liked host and you two had been
in touch was it this is the kind of
situation where you saw that movie you
liked it so much and you reached out to
him no I was wondering was not the case
um I loved host I thought it was
incredible it was one of the great gifts
uh to us horror hounds during the
pandemic
but no I was sent this script
by uh Dan the man on the board there Dan
Cohen of 21 laps who I've known for a
long time and Dan
um said
this is the role the director and I
think it's perfect for you you got to do
it and I read it and I said absolutely
not no interest in portraying Lester
Billings I don't care to go there I
don't I've done too too much stuff in
the darkness I need a break and I can't
do it and then Dan is many things A
Gifted producer a wonderful human being
but he's also like Relentless and he
just kept
talking to me and saying if I could just
get you to talk to Rob and hear his
vision of what you know who he thinks
that Lester could be and what you could
do with it I was like I don't I don't I
just I don't know if I have the capacity
in me right now to go where you need to
go we're coming out of a pandemic it's
been a dark time in all of our Lives you
know bring to life a guy who in many
ways just represents so many of the
things that scare me the most about this
life
and then of course that fateful Zoom
finally happens with Rob Savage and I go
I love this guy
yeah we're gonna do this movie together
so what did he say during that Zoom that
that not only gave you the confidence in
him that he'd be a good leader for you
to work on this part with but also in
yourself that you could go there do it
well but also be able to come out of it
immediately I got the
truth of Rob's
Vision as a director that spoke to his
insistence that this was going to be a
overall film
um that was not constructed for the
device of mirror entertainment or scarce
and that uh character like Lester was
not a mere device as a conduit of
information and as
for lack of a better term a kind of
Trope a kind of caricature of the
Southern Yokel guy that um I kind of got
the feeling that he was in the short
story and he understood why
this
world was going to lean more towards the
creation and telling of a story
something like uh Ordinary People as
opposed to
um
scarehouse so I was like okay
I'm listening and he started talking
about the need to really invite you know
Chris's characters mind and heart into a
place uh with this interaction that he
has with Lester that then is going to
open a door for the audience to become
vulnerable and start caring about these
people in a way that will be meaningful
because it's talking about a subject
that's actually really meaningful to me
lost
really important people to me over the
last few years grief is a it is as
horrifying as some of the human emotions
can be that we experience and
watching and hearing Rob talk that first
conversation with
the genuine
and authentic care that he had about it
meant a lot to me
I have so many follow-up questions the
first one the first one that I really
want to make sure I ask you and it I
feel like there's going to be no simple
answer to this but what is it like
playing Lester in a way where the
audience needs to to feel for him for
his loss and and sympathize with him a
bit but then also have him have like a
Sinister presence where the audience
knows that by him stepping into that
house something bad could happen at any
second so
in embodying what it is that Lester
needs to bring to the table in this
story I felt like I was going to be
juggling a couple of different balls
that were really important and the first
and foremost most important to me was
creating a human being that hopefully
people could believe could connect to
could understand
um if they didn't have maybe Lester's
life experience or they didn't come from
his part of the world they could at
least see in him a commonality in the
way that they feel like sometimes their
suffering is so isolating and then
because of the nature of the story that
we're telling because of the tone of the
film that Rob's making and because of
the source material that comes from the
King himself
there is something that needs to keep
everybody including Chris who plays Will
on their toes what is Lester up to like
what is this guy capable of what is
about to happen that's the storytelling
fun there's that device
um in Great Horror uh that
you try to craft a a narrative where
people are just so on the edge of their
seats because they don't know what's
going to happen next so you're doing
that while at the same time trying to
ground this in
you know real human emotion that's that
scene it's it keeps you on the edge of
your seat but draws you in at the same
time and like you're you're getting
dangerously close but you can't help
yourself I love it it was great to shoot
it was a gift it was like being back in
theater and I loved
um knowing that at any second things
could implode things could go sideways
uh you take a lot of risk when you're
you know choosing to act in different
ways and I felt like with this I wanted
to really
be as vulnerable as I possibly could so
that we could create attention again I
think that scene just has so much weight
on it you have to really crank up the
tension for this film and really
introduce some ideas and Concepts that
are going to then Propel us into the
rest of this story so
I was so scared like taking on that
responsibility as well just because of
the fear of going places you know
emotionally and physically but also the
pressure of like this scene has to work
this scene needs to work if it doesn't
work
film doesn't work you brought this up
and we spoke a bit about it at the press
conference if this is the scariest role
you've ever tackled and
it makes me wonder what is number two
they're all scary to be quite honest I I
was terrified I made a film called
animals that deals with addiction
um that was terrifying for me because I
am someone who's you know uh dealt with
addiction and mental illness uh my most
of my life uh 21 years clean this year
but I feel like any time you go into
that space making yourself vulnerable
and
did a film called prisoners with Denise
Villeneuve and playing Bob Taylor it was
really tricky for me because
um it deals with some of the themes and
things that scare me the most about this
life
um
I recently did a film called late night
with the devil which really scared me in
mental breakdowns there's a lot
um on stage as well
but Lester was its own
kind of fear bringing Lester Billings
to life
and being a part of this film was like
its own kind of Terror that Terror was
well worth jumping into you're so good
thank you so you bring up Denny there
and you've worked with so many
incredible directors now including raw
we've got Chris Nolan James gone I could
go on and on
they're all different filmmakers but do
you notice a shared quality that they
all have that signal to you that they
are directing great and also an ideal
collaborator for me there's absolutely
one commonality because they're all so
different I've been so blessed I've
gotten to work with David Lynch and
James gone and Chris Nolan Denny villain
of you know paid and read Rob Savage I
can't even so many it's embarrassing
because I know I'll forget to say
somebody but the the one link the thing
that unites them all and Rob has this is
a confidence in their Vision they know
what it is that they need to achieve
they know what every scene is about they
know the tone the world that they're
building and they may have different
ways of going about bringing that to
life different styles different Energies
that's wonderful but as soon as you step
into the ring with them and you know
that they've got the confidence that
they know exactly where they need to get
you to and that they can help carry you
there
um with the you know power of both their
preparation their discipline their hard
work their talent and their that magical
gift thing
um
helps you just give yourself over to
whatever they need beautiful answer I
wanted to wrap with one Oppenheimer
question because you were just talking
about some of your fears tackling a
challenging role and I've heard Chris
Nolan say that that was one of his most
challenging projects he's ever done and
given what I've seen of his in the past
I I can't imagine why anything is a
challenge for him anymore so from your
Vantage Point on that set what are you
looking around and maybe spotting as a
real big challenge for a notora like
Christopher Nolan that's a tough
question because
when you're on set
with
when you're on set with Christopher
Nolan I assure you there's no
clue as to what it is that maybe
haunting him or
um
instilling any kind of
fear in him because
he's such a great
leader
so you just feel the confidence coming
from him that is not ego
and it's not Pride it's just true
confidence that he has a story he needs
to tell
and you're lucky enough to get to be a
part of the ride I would believe that I
would believe that thank you so much
congratulations thank you I appreciate
it thank you